[Music]
Hollywood has officially released
another big-budget Robin Hood story and
you probably didn't see it what happened
to make this reimagining stray so far
from the target and what could have been
done differently let's break down the
real reasons Robin Hood bombed at the
box office
Robin Hood attempted to revive a classic
folk tale with style and flair with a
cast including Taron Egerton Jamie Foxx
and Jamie Dornan the movie tries to tell
a dark and gritty origin story along the
lines of Batman Begins the movie's
modern approach includes over-the-top
combat scenes with automatic crossbows
explosions and super stylish archery
Robin Hood himself has given a
personality upgrade to the outlaw has
long been understood to be a champion of
the commoner but now he's a class war
leading revolutionary with a puzzling
modern wardrobe this is departure from
your father's Robin this has had a dope
twist to it but all of these appeals to
modern tastes totally missed the mark
with audiences leaving the movie falling
flat on his face over the long
Thanksgiving weekend no matter how you
look at it Robin Hood was off to a
disastrous start only claiming the
number 7 spots of the domestic box
office in his first weekend of release
in the United States it brought in just
over 14 million dollars against the
budget of reportedly close to 100
million dollars with the movie having
debuted on over 2,700 screens that would
seem to suggest a lots of empty theatres
things seem equally dismal for Robin
Hood outside of the US with the movie
only bringing in around 8.7 million
dollars from foreign markets the
performance made for total earnings of
about 23 million dollars after the
movie's first weekend enough for some
commenters to call it one of the biggest
bombs of the year making things worse
that 100 million dollar production
budget only covers cost before marketing
meaning the movie is likely way more in
the red than the public will ever get to
know it's stunning how much money was
sunk into this movie since despite all
of its name recognition it was never a
sure thing it's too dangerous but the
danger is what makes it fun
those are 2018 Robin Hood movie was
marketed with the tagline that the
legend do you know the story you don't
that's little more than wishful thinking
this story is extremely well known the
Robin Hood folktale has been told in
films literally dozens of times to the
point where even the most disengaged
person could rattle off the stories
basics Robin Hood has a green hat a bow
and arrow and a loyal CRO he Rob's from
the rich and gives to the poor there's a
friar named Chuck a maid named Marian
and a John who is little they're all
foxes you get the idea how does a studio
generate excitement for a story has been
done to death over 700 years it's a good
question and one this movie clearly
failed to crack Robin Hood's lukewarm
reception can partially be attributed to
a lack of interesting star power
director Otto Bathurst reportedly waited
a year for lead actor Taron Egerton to
become available for this reimagining
being determined to see him in the role
but why he explained his decision to the
corium male saying I wanted to find
someone who was accessible and who
seemed real and Taryn is like guy he is
incredibly charismatic and charming but
he also has serious intensity Terrance
got a really fantastic
everyman about him serving up the
emotional drama and then also fun
despite a relatively solid critical
track record
Edgerton has never proven himself to be
a huge draw in a lead role at least
outside of the success of the
star-studded Kingsman movies despite
technically being the protagonist of
that series edgerton's role has
generally been but one small part for
more famous ensemble even with a capable
assist from Jamie Foxx and others it's
possible that this cast just wasn't
enough of a draw for the well-worn
material if Robin Hood had come out
during a baron weekend in January it
might have stood a chance
instead it made its debut drawing one of
the most parked released windows of the
whole year and got trampled coming in at
number one over the long Thanksgiving
weekend was Ralph breaks the internet
the wreck-it Ralph si call that stunned
his competition with the second best
Thanksgiving opening ever the movie also
debuted below Creed to the crinch
fantastic beast - and Bohemian Rhapsody
it even performed worse than the
modestly budgeted Mark Wahlberg comedy
instant family which was holding on to
6th place in his second week during
Robin Hood's roll outs apparently all
six of these movies
more compelling options for holiday
moviegoers once again suggesting the
audiences really don't care about the
Robin Hood story anymore
all of these factors could have been
overcome if Robin Hood had turned out to
be an awesome movie but it unfortunately
debuted to a dismal reception from
critics and audiences alike Rotten
Tomatoes counting roughly 100 reviews
initially tallied a 13% approval rating
for the movie making it one of the worst
received adaptations of the Robin Hood
story yet it also got a middling Beach
cinema score which tends not to
translate into positive word-of-mouth on
the other hand between it's weird
costumes and other strained anachronisms
there's a lot about Robin Hood the
audiences are found amusing Richard
Roeper writing for the Chicago sun-times
even said that the film is legitimately
funny it has the makings of a movie
that's so off base and over-the-top that
it actually becomes good but that kind
of reputation usually isn't enough to
make the hundred million dollars this
movie desperately needs more Robin Hood
may have enough of a spark of madness to
be kind of entertaining it doesn't seem
to be working on audiences and the way
as producers intended
despite sending where the sequel tease
it seems doubtful at this point that the
tale will continue hopefully the next
people who try and make a movie out of
Robin Hood take the hint we know this
story already maybe it's just time for
something new
[Music]